[Musica]
Che cosa Che cosa è stato
nessuno
[Musica]
che qualcuno
forse è un uccello notturno
[Musica]
Io non ho paura
Ciao Anita è arrivata questa lettera
strana è indirizzata a te ma non so da
parte di chi per Anita Stories da fiamma
e chi è fiamma Non lo so Che nome strano
vediamo cosa c'è scritto
sembra una lettera molto lunga Cara
Anita Stories questa
strana ma non potevo scriverti
neanche qualcun altro potesse leggere
queste parole mi chiamo fiamma e sto
cercando disperatamente qualcuno che
possa aiutarmi con un enorme problema
non ho trovato nessuno esperto in
materia
Tranne Te ti starai chiedendo di che
problema si tratti Ebbene il mio
problema è una creatura
uno ho bisogno del tuo aiuto perché temo
di fare una brutta fine avrai più
dettagli una volta che ci saremo
incontrati dobbiamo assolutamente
aiutarla
Segui la mappa e arriverai da me fiamma
qui guarda e anche qua vicino subito
allora
sembra proprio questo il posto ma non
c'è nessuno proviamo andare di là
guarda lì
sai che cos'è questa
no Che cos'è un Orma gigante
a giudicare dalla grandezza della
profondità sembra che sia stata lasciata
da una creatura di almeno 100 kg 100 kg
e da quando sei diventata così brava
nelle deduzioni Beh da quando abbiamo
affrontato tutte quelle creature prima
ma adesso sbrighiamoci questa signora
fiamma potrebbe essere in pericolo
Mi sembra di vedere qualcosa forse la
casa è lì Sì andiamo presto ok Deve
essere quella
teniamo gli occhi aperti però eh
Sì è meglio Ho sentito gli occhiali da
sole così ci vedi meglio Hai ragione
che c'è ho dimenticato qualcosa da
mangiare l'aria aperta di campagna
Guarda c'è profumo lì
deve essere lei fiamma Credo di sì
Sì aiuto Vitale avete deciso di venire
ad aiutarvi venite
accomodatevi in casa Grazie
Ciao ciao
E tu devi essere Anita Vitale
[Musica]
Ciao ciao benvenuti Finalmente avete
deciso di venire qui
ma accomodatevi pure moderati
mettiti pure comodo Innanzitutto ragazzi
Volevo ringraziarvi per avere deciso di
aiutarmi
Scusate scusate
come vi ho scritto anche nella lettera
siete le uniche persone che ho trovato
Capaci in questo campo e che album sono
veramente salati
[Risate]
per caso non so avete delle domande Beh
in realtà sì sì tantissime
Sarà l'aria di campagna però non
producendo la corriera Non è che per
caso avrebbe dei biscotti Non pensare
sempre a mangiare stiamo parlando di una
creatura è grave la situazione ti avevo
chiesto solo dei biscotti Eh adesso se
ci avevamo delle domande oggi sta roba
hai visto
ucciso
un'oretta
però però ho del tempo buonissimo Se
volete ve lo posso dire ehm allora i
bicchieri
Ecco qua
Dunque
è Anita il verde e sai il mio colore
preferito è un po' strano Questa signora
tu ti fidi di questo suo hotel Sì è vero
un po' strana però c'è un colore Strano
questo trailer In effetti
Ma sì dai che cosa vuoi che succeda
prego
grazie grazie finito il verde ehm e
dunque per me qui ho un dolore un po'
strano effettivamente
ma è buonissimo
l'hai bevuto Davvero buonissimo
delizioso Il mio tè sapete l'ho fatto
con dei fiori che crescono spontanei nel
mio giardino
bellissimo
ma torniamo a noi io avrei un po' di
domande a riguardo di questa creatura
Innanzitutto cosa ti fa pensare che sia
realmente una creatura potrebbe anche
essere magari un animale selvatico
Cioè hai visto qualcosa Non lo so tipo
c'è qualche dettaglio in più e mi verso
un altro po' di te Scusate
Ecco qui delizioso
ottima domanda dritta dritta al punto
vedete
sono convinta che si tratti di una
creatura per diversi motivi e proprio
l'altro giorno Mentre sistemavo il mio
giardino ho visto un Impro
talmente grande che ci sono entrambi i
miei piedi e pensate che avanzava anche
altro spazio Oggi abbiamo visto noi e
quelli fantastici neanche capitato di
vedere degli enormi Grazie su mia
amatissimi alberi di ulivo
graffi profondi
ma non era un gatto così
insomma
Quale animale è selvatico sarebbe così
gigante
se no non una creatura famelica che sta
cercando probabilmente di prendere le
olive e raccoglierle e farne l'olio
vaccinandolo per poi soffriggermi e
mangiarli con aglio e peperoncino
[Applauso]
lo so che un'idea folle Eh ho pensato
anche a questo Beh in realtà non credo
che una creatura abbia bisogno di
cucinarti per mangiarti Ma vabbè come Ma
se io fossi una creatura lo farei è come
se lo farei il cibo cotto è molto più
buono
se tu fossi una creatura basterebbero 20
secondi per catturati basterebbe mettere
dei biscotti o qualsiasi altro cibo Tu
sentiresti l'odore a 10 km di distanza e
ma torniamo a noi c'è un'altra cosa che
non vi ho detto io la creatura
l'ho incontrata
subito che forma aveva sì che creatura
era Allora
in realtà non sono sicura di averla
vista molto bene in pratica stavo
innaffiando i fiori nel mio giardino
quando un botto alle mie
spalle a dare e gli occhiali
ssima e per fortuna sono riuscita a
chiudermi in casa così bene almeno sei
riuscita a metterti in salvo e non ti
sei fatta male Sì infatti Beh comunque
abbiamo una pista adesso mi servono
giusto più dettagli ad esempio quanto
era alta la creatura hai visto Insomma
Di che colore era ehm
non lo so Ho qualche altro dettaglio che
potrebbe aiutarvi
Non lo so buccia di banana Sì insomma
andarci più informazioni possibili ok e
non l'ho vista bene ma sono sicura che
era molto più alta di me era da poco
calato il sole quando oltre al forte
boato ho sentito il suo respiro
affallato che mi inseguiva mentre vai
Brivi
stai pensando anche tu quello a cui sto
pensando io no non ci credo È per questo
che andiamo così d'accordo anche tu
stavi pensando una pizza margherita
gigante vero
no creatura di quelle dimensioni che si
Gira di notte restringe molto il campo
quindi non stavi pensando alla vita No
non è il momento di pensare alla pizza
margherita
credo di essere vicino alla soluzione
Credo di aver capito che creatura
potrebbe essere ma ho bisogno ancora di
indagare a questo caso è sono sicura che
riusciremo a risolverlo però abbiamo
bisogno di indagare ancora abbiamo
bisogno di raccogliere più indizi
Certamente avete tutta la casa a
disposizione anzi io ho tantissime cose
da fare per cui vi lascio liberi di
perlustrare
A dopo ragazzi Ok ciao a dopo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ma
è un po' Strana molto molto strana Direi
che non perdiamo tempo dobbiamo editare
le indagini la creatura ma non pensare a
te adesso non sappiamo neanche cosa ci
ha messo dentro buono e dolce la cretina
potrebbe essere ancora qua nei paraggi
forse
Allora lei ha detto che l'ha incontrata
la sera al calar del Sole fuori quindi
ovviamente dobbiamo iniziare ad indagare
fuori sì Tra l'altro sta anche calando
il sole quindi forse è il caso che
iniziamo ad indagare la fuori Anzi
dobbiamo proprio sbrigarci andiamo
Ehi aspetta un momento
questo odore
vogliono fregare a me non ci riusciranno
[Musica]
No qui no
lo sapevo pensavano di fregare me
eh Che bel vassoio di biscotti
[Musica]
Sbrigati
male Muoviti dove sei arrivo
Certo che questo giardino è grandissimo
Ci metteremo un sacco a trovare degli
indizi Eh sì è proprio gigante Ma che
cos'è che stavamo cercando nello
specifico come cosa stavamo cercando
fiamma ci ha detto di indagare per
scoprire di Che creatura si tratta
dobbiamo salvarla Cioè dobbiamo anche
salvare noi stessi adesso perché se non
risolviamo questo caso la creatura verrà
a cercare anche noi cioè la creatura
mangerà a noi Io voglio mangiare Cioè io
voglio mangiare ma non voglio essere
mangiato dalla creatura Appunto allora
sbrighiamoci cerchiamo degli indizi è
arrivato il momento di sbrigarsi
Ecco qua il nostro primo indizio ma che
cos'è questo credo sia un pezzo
stracciato di vestito
ma prima dicevi che forse avevi intuito
qualcosa si trattava di questo ha
intuito qualcosa in quello che ha detto
fiamma perché ha detto che la creatura è
comparsa di notte ed è alta più di due
metri Sì è alta più di 2 metri quindi
sai che cosa può essere Sì beh Dunque
alta 2 metri sarà sicuramente l'alce
nero dell'Abruzzo no
stiamo parlando di animali stiamo
parlando di creature Sappiamo anche
sbrigarci perché questa creatura deve
avere smangiucchiato una persona
Molto bene molto bene i ragazzi devono
essere dall'altra parte della casa e io
allora potrò preparare tutte le mie
meravigliose pozioni
[Applauso]
Ecco l'altro pezzo ma
dobbiamo cercare gli indizi capito Dai
sbrigati
ora che Anita Vitale non ci sono posso
finalmente continuare con la mia con la
mia scoperta il mio segreto
Eccomi qua è amatissime e dunque con
cautela con cantina
appoggio qui e calderone
Ecco che cos'era Secondo te questo
indumento una maglietta un vestito boh
sembra tipo una canottiera di uomo di
una donna
tutto bene
[Musica]
puzza di ascella e di cane bagnato com'è
possibile tutte e due insieme dai
cerchiamo gli altri pezzi di vestito se
ce ne sono
Siamo partiti da là sì forse dobbiamo
continuare verso la Ok proviamo a
controllare di là allora
vomito
vomito di ranocchio
Ah sì è perfetto
quanto basta Guarda laggiù Dove là in
fondo
c'è il resto degli indumenti che abbiamo
trovato prima tutti strappati quindi la
creatura potrebbe essere l'albero
qua vicino
credo sia proprio questa Aspetta aspetta
non toccarla prima assicuriamoci che sia
la stessa lo stesso indumento che
abbiamo trovato
vediamo che indumento è detto guarda Si
vede proprio che è una canottiera vero
eroe canottiera Ma perché ce n'è solo
metà Questa potrebbe essere o la vittima
della creatura Oppure era della creatura
stessa che
Ma lo sai che non ci avevo pensato
e quindi trasformandosi è strappato la
canottiera Il che vuol dire che è una
creatura che si trasforma quindi non una
creatura di forma normale che rimane
sempre una creatura ma una creatura che
si trasforma in questo restringe il
cerchio ancora di più è un Transformers
una pala la creatura è una pala l'ho
capito adesso c'è un problema adesso che
problema la creatura o ha sepolto
qualcosa lì da dentro Sì anche se è un
po' strana la seconda Anche secondo me
lo è che cosa facciamo rischiamo andiamo
a disseppellire qualsiasi cosa ci sia là
dentro E va bene Abbiamo dissotterrato
Qualsiasi cosa ci sia là sotto Ho paura
di scoprire che cosa c'è lì in realtà
due altre Orme
quindi vuol dire che non veniva di là
veniva di qua la creatura oppure è
entrata in casa dopo
non ci avevo pensato ma ora di
sotterriamo quella cosa che sta là sotto
vediamo se ci dà qualche Altro indizio
va bene andiamo dai
e poi il blu il blu mal di mare quanto
basta Comunque io ti volevo dire che non
mi sembra proprio una grande idea questa
eh
Vedi c'è una fossa e poi ci sono anche i
fiori a fianco Vorrà dire che
sicuramente ci hanno seppellito qualcuno
qui Oh no spero di no ma dobbiamo
scoprirlo solo così riusciremo a capire
che creatura è aspetta Se invece poi è
uno zombie è alto 2 metri grazie agli
alberi No è vero Gli zombie No non
graffiano gli alberi Dobbiamo capire che
cosa ha seppellito qua sotto Ok dai
proviamo Proviamo a vedere che cosa c'è
piano piano eh Okay okay
te l'ho detto che c'è qualcosa c'è lo
zombie là dentro eh lascialo lì dove
stanno di nuovo c'ho paura lasciaci
penso io
Che cos'è
[Musica]
sembra
sembrano delle scaglie di Gigi un
animale
che schifo uno scarafaggio forse gigante
però Toglila tu Attenta ai fiori
Dai sbrigati piano però non so neanche
che cosa ci devo andare con cautela qui
guarda che schifo Che cos'è e sembra un
e che cos'è questo non capisco
sembra un uovo un uovo ma Pasqua è già
passata cosa c'entra e poi perché sotto
terra
e se fosse l'uovo della creatura
la creatura che depone le uova Sì tipo
una salamandra un rettile ma una
salamandra non depone delle uova così
grandi è una salamandra creatura alta
Beh Dobbiamo chiedere a fiamma delle
spiegazioni meglio che torniamo dentro
casa Sono d'accordo con te
[Musica]
andiamo fiori di primavera
così e poi
voi aggiungerei della polvere polvere di
nuvole così ma forse un altro po'
ecco qua
molto bene
il profumo è delizioso
questa deve essere la camera da letto
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa qua
Comunque non ti sembra un po' strano che
fiamma si è dileguata così velocemente
dicendo che aveva da fare Hai dei
sospetti su di lei
forse quasi però ho visto che siamo in
camera da letto di fiamma Potremmo
cercare qualche indizio Ok magari li
nasconde qualcosa Sì sono d'accordo con
te Non vi sembra un po' strana anche a
voi magari proprio qua troveremo
qualcosa che ci farà capire se
lei potrebbe essere la creatura Davvero
pensi che sia meglio la creatura non ne
sono sicura ma dobbiamo cercare qualche
indizio se fosse lei la creatura
dovremmo scappare velocissimamente loro
loro liquefatto ce n'è poco dovrò andare
di nuovo giù nei sotterranei a prenderne
un altro po'
cerchiamo di trovare qualcosa
ma ci sono solo vestiti e tutto così
normale qua
ci fate qui nella mia camera
non sono stato io beh stavamo indagando
come ti avevamo detto e siamo finiti
nella tua camera perché
nascondi qualcosa
Ah no le mie faccende
i biscotti i biscotti penso i biscotti
non vorrei che si fossero bruciati
uno strano odorino Ci vediamo dopo
ragazzi a dopo
hai notato anche tu Sì l'ho notato
anch'io adesso che i biscotti si sono
bruciati ma non c'è proprio puzza di
biscotti bruciati no Non penserai
biscotti qua c'era un oggetto sembrava
una sorta di una piuma Forse l'ha presa
ed è andata via e ha detto che deve
svolgere delle faccende con
quell'oggetto si fa ancora più sospetta
fiamme No non mi dire Magari tortura le
sue vittime con quella piuma
Ma no E poi usa la piuma per spalmare la
glassa sui biscotti No Come no E allora
che cosa ci pago quella piuma mi è
venuto l'idea non ci posso credere Ho
avuto un'idea geniale pediniamola
andiamo a vedere che cosa sta facendo
sai che questa volta hai avuto proprio
un'ottima idea Ci stavo pensando anch'io
seguiamo la spiaamole vediamo cosa sta
combinando veramente Andiamo ragazzi
capello è sempre necessario
Ecco qui
è quasi pronto aggiungerei
spremuta di melanzane
non lo sopporto
[Musica]
non si sente niente Anita
sbirciamo
l'eccessivo dire eccessivo
si sentono rumori strani
Dai fammi controllare
piano piano mica se ne accorgerà
Eccola qua Ma sì aggiungiamone un altro
pochino
si vede bene l'ultima goccia del
liquamed siamo però non mi spingere
non mi spinge l'ho detto
Cosa ci fate qui
No cosa ho fatto attenzione